[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in this video we're going to be
discussing an iconic symbol in harry
potter
and that is harry's scar we all know how
he got it
and what it looks like but i don't think
that its signature lightning bolt shape
has ever been properly explained why
does it look the way that it does
is this lightning bolt shape significant
on the 31st of october 1981
lord voldemort entered the home of lily
james and harry potter
and attempted to murder them all
voldemort was successful in killing
harry's parents
lily and james but wasn't able to kill
harry as a result of his mother's
sacrificial protection when voldemort
cast the killing curse avada kadavra
on harry he inadvertently turned harry
into a horcrux
embedding a piece of his own soul inside
of harry and forging a connection
between the two when harry was old
enough to attend hogwarts he was
introduced to the wizarding world
where he was met with praise and fame
having survived an attack from the dark
lord himself
for years harry's scar caused him pain
particularly when lord voldemort
was close by jk rowling herself has
stated that the pain emanating from his
scar
is actually caused by the piece of
voldemort's soul attempting to leave
harry's body
so that it can rejoin its master's soul
the connection between the two of them
was
strong and it wasn't until voldemort
died that harry's pain stopped
so with that brief backstory established
we can confirm a few things
number one harry has a lightning bolt
shaped scar
number two voldemort attempted to kill
him with avada kadavra
and three harry's mother used
sacrificial protection
so with all of this information in mind
the question remains
why on earth is the scar in the shape of
a lightning bolt
lightning bolts are cool and all but we
haven't seen lightning bolts mentioned
anywhere
so what's the significance one theory is
that the signature
lightning bolt shape is actually the
shape of the wand movement
when casting avada kedavra here we can
see the one movement for vadik davra
looks familiar doesn't it despite the
perhaps slightly more jagged edges of
harry's scar
they look pretty identical this
explanation is unfortunately less
exciting
than preposterous alternatives like
harry's lightning scar gives him the
powers of thor
and harry has super speed like the flash
however
what's a little unusual about this
theory is that in the movies and books
neither voldemort nor the death eaters
appear to cast avada kadavra
in this fashion for the most part they
just point their wand in a straight line
and stay to the incantation i think that
the original source of this
wand movement comes from the games and
i'm not convinced that they are
canonically consistent
perhaps this means that there is a
stronger connection between avada
kadavra
and the scar than we might have
originally thought there are two
theories for how avada kadava kills
people
the first claiming that the victim's
internal organs cease to function
after being struck and the second
claiming the soul of the victim
is magically ripped from their body i
feel like this second theory
bears some merit if lily potter used
sacrificial protection on harry
this would have severely interfered with
the traditional process
of evada cadaver which perhaps could
have caused the spell
to be stunted i think that something
like this happened
due to the sheer force of avada kadavra
and lord voldemort's power
the spell initially made successful
contact with harry
however as harry's soul was ripped from
his body the sacrificial protection
provided by lily
stopped the spell in its tracks
inflicting a physical mark on harry
to the clashing of powerful magic
simultaneously
voldemort's spell caused harry to become
a horcrux and a piece of his soul
entered into harry's body through the
same point of contact
reinforcing the injury that harry had
already sustained
the signature lightning bolt shape was
the result of voldemort's spell
changing direction creating three points
the first point was created when the
killing curse first hit harry
the second point created when lilly's
sacrificial protection kicked in
and clashed with it and the third point
being when the killing curse rebounded
back toward lord voldemort i know that
traditionally the killing curse doesn't
leave a mark
but these are extenuating circumstances
what do you guys think
do you think that harry's scar is
related to the wand movement
vivadicadavra
or something else altogether how about
the three-point theory
leave a comment down below until next
time it does not do to dwell on dreams
and forget to live